now aryans did have
a message yesterday we talked about
this split squad
sanctioned workout unsanctioned workout
tom brady and his band of merry men at
the yankees facility and the guys who
are working out under the auspices of
the buccaneers in their ota sessions
here's aaron's being asked a question
about uh the fact that plenty of guys
aren't there for him to evaluate
what did you not see today that you wish
you had seen
about 10 more players
these guys out here working their ass
off but i'd like to see about 10 more of
them that are fighting for jobs that
they don't know they're fighting for
uh technically countries are not allowed
to say anything that would suggest that
these sessions are not voluntary and
frankly if the union wanted to yeah an
issue they could i don't i don't think
they will but
that that that's that's
one of the reasons why
when the union launched this effort to
stay away from the otas we said hey
there are guys who need to be there or
they're not going to have a chance to
compete for one of the roster spots it's
one of the things that makes this
different from a regular union you got
90 guys on that roster right now for the
buccaneers 37 of them will not be on the
roster come week one
and there are 10 of them
that don't realize
the trouble they're in and they're not
there for bruce arians to see what
they're able to do
as of right now and uh that that's the
conversation that needs to be had
between that's right player and agent
yeah so the player is aware of his life
the jeopardy that the players in no
doubt or the player needs to call the
coaches too and then kind of get you
know the
whatever the the the you know
give me the lay of the land what's going
on see and aaron's will tell you aaron's
we'll tell you i would think everybody
on that staff would shoot you straight i
don't think bruce would hire a guy
unless you know he just shoots it
straight that's the way he is that's why
he's just in here right yeah and he said
it you're right he's kind of flirting
with the breaking the rules by saying
that but i also think he says it out of
like the goodness of his heart to be
like kind of sent a warning to these
players like hey man like come on
you know you don't know sometimes again
a quarterback is different you know when
you're having to compete oh they drafted
this guy they signed him as a free agent
sometimes you could be and this is not
the best scenario a middle linebacker
right i know the bucks and the
linebackers are good and they're not
they don't have to worry about anything
but like you could be a middle
linebacker who's been starting the last
two or three years and maybe there's a
guy going into year two at linebacker
and then they drafted a guy in the
fourth or fifth round
you might not really realize that the
organization is kind of not as happy
with your play as you are
and
that there is a thought of replacing you
until you are at the facility and all of
a sudden they you start doing things
that are rep oriented right mike that's
when sometimes players realize like oh
crap
i took the first three reps with the
first team but the first team stayed out
there and they put the other guy in for
the last three reps uh oh
i'm in i'm competing for my job
sometimes players don't really know that
they're
on the line that way
until they're out with the team and
they're doing drills and things like
that and there's a pecking order thrown
out there by the coach of your position
and you start to realize wait holy crap
i might not be assured to be the starter
here or make the team and i think that's
what bruce arians is speaking to and i
think that's a big problem around the
league right now with some of these
middle to older veteran type players
and what's surprising about this is
bruce arians presumably has gotten his
point across already and those guys
still aren't there i would think he's
made sure they know right i would think
so even if you don't say it directly to
the player
you're never going to get in trouble
with the union for calling up a player's
agent and saying you better tell your
guy to get his ass here if he wants a
job this season because he doesn't
realize that he's in a competition and
again that's what makes this whole union
construct
awkward
you've got union brethren
who are all vying
for the same limited number of jobs and
uh it's it's just it's it's not it's not
easy
to get
the players to engage in collective
action like that to stay away when a
certain number of them really need to be
there because they're they're being
evaluated and there's less opportunity
to evaluate
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports